this will be harder for good students
that's me I was so I'm say the best
student hi I'm Stephanie I have been a
teacher for three years hey my name is
Ted I've been a teacher for about five
years my name is Ryan I've been a
teacher for two years and I'm also a
tutor for the SATs and a CT and today
I'm going to do my best to get out of
detention okay
earlier today miss Finkelstein the worst
teacher ever gave you detention
she looks pretty mean wow that's really
inconvenient for you because tonight is
the Spring Fling and your chance to get
with Taylor that cutie in the grade this
looks like a fun little party you only
have one choice sneak out of detention
don't get caught or damaged school
property or else you won't be able to go
to Spring Fling I probably wasn't
invited I'm going either way no school
can hold me okay we got a message from
Taylor hey are you coming tonight
Taylor texted me oh I'm emotionally
involved now okay what will you respond
totally I'll be there that's a silly
question wouldn't miss it you I'm
definitely going to try who if like I
shouldn't pull my phone out in detention
but that's not a choice here so I think
we're gonna project an air of confidence
here Taylor doesn't need to know my
whole life story and I don't want her or
him to think I'm a bad boy
or maybe I do hmm I'm gonna say that's a
silly question cuz then it still leaves
it open so let me see have to text me
back I'd say I'm definitely going to try
I'm gonna say totally I'll be there you
tuck your phone into your pocket and
start planning an exit strategy you'll
have to distract mrs. Finkelstein and
either get out the window or sneak out
of the classroom door you guys let's
think about this for a minute am I going
out the door or through the window I
would go out the classroom door now
here's the thing I'm a climber right
when I would go to the park as a kid I
would my mom would be like don't get up
in the trees and she's the moment she
turned around I was at the top of the
tree so I think I'm going out the window
look I it's not normal to see people
jump out of a window so they will just
go out the classroom door
mrs. Finkelstein is going over all of
the detention rules she's honestly the
worst I agree it's time for an escape
plan pick a distraction raise your hand
and say you have to go to the bathroom
or raise your hand and tell her you
think you see her car getting towed I
would say raise your hand to tell her
you think your car is being towed I
think I'm gonna say that her car is
getting towed just cuz that sounds like
more fun raising more mischief this
teacher is truly the worst ever she
probably doesn't have a lot of empathy
so her having any empathy from my
situation would be a a longshot
if you will so let's say I think you see
her car getting towed because she's
probably super selfish mr. Finkelstein
looks at you and says do you think I was
born yesterday you respond no I think
you were born alongside the dinosaurs
nope I would say that or seriously don't
you drive a blue Nissan Altima oh man I
think I need to know what kind of car
she drives because if she doesn't drive
a blue Nissan Altima than that then that
line of questioning is ruined I'm not
getting out I'd probably still go with
it and say seriously don't you drive a
blue Nissan Altima pretty clever so I
think I'm gonna say I think you're born
alongside the dinosaurs r.i.p oh you
honestly didn't think that would go well
did you mr. Finkelstein made you stay
until 8:00 p.m. called your parents and
you're grounded the rest of the weekend
you also have to write an apology note
to miss Finkelstein hey on the upside
the entire class thinks you're super
cool I think they might have already
thought that and because me and Taylor
made a great couple
mrs. Finkelstein turns around and looks
out the window when she does you bolt
out the door and start booking it down
the hall she noticed you were missing
you hear her calling out to you you have
to hide but where so either the
custodians closet or the library if I'm
in detention she probably won't look for
me in the library so I'm gonna say the
library library you get to the library
only to see miss involve working late
checking in books she greets you and
asks you what you're doing here so late
you reply I'm here to check out a good
book I really don't have time to talk I
just wanted to see how you were doing it
is Miss Inbal who knows maybe we can't
always get what we want but we may find
what we need I would say I'm here to
check out a bit
I'm gonna say I just wanted to see how
you were doing oh she looks so nice oh
wow
miss Engvall ends up talking to you
about art politics and before you know
it you've checked out 57 books from the
library and it's 8:30 p.m. you had a
blast with your librarian but forgot
about the Spring Fling you might want to
ask miss invol to prom because taylors
sure isn't going with you she started
talking to you about her life you can
stay and talk to her you can risk
upsetting here and just leave you know
what stands out you never know what kind
of connections you're gonna make in the
library and maybe gain a friend as well
as super detention red is good right
okay you might want to ask a Miss
Engvall to prom because Taylor sure
doesn't want to go with you
so I didn't make it out of the detention
hopefully Taylor waits for me and when I
get out she waits for me on the outside
I guess I'm a little disappointed that
sounds like me I usually lose track of
time
well I technically escaped detention I
didn't get caught but it sounds like
there might be a future for me and
missing ball it's nice to have a
challenging engaging conversation that's
not just two people sitting in a room
looking at their phones I guess you know
if I wanted to make it to the Spring
Fling I would have said I'm busy or
whatever to the librarian and then like
I would have been able to make it on
time well I probably would have done
everything the same but then I may have
gone back one step and wrists offending
her and stepping out to move along I
probably picked the door I think that
the door was the key I was trying to get
creative and might go out the window
just because I felt like that fit my
personality more but the door seems like
the more logical choice I could have
just said go to that I had to go to the
bathroom and like is she really gonna
make me stay I don't know maybe I have a
bladder infection or something miss
finkelstein who are you to judge so I go
to the bathroom I get out I'm gone I'm
at the dance before she knows what
happened I think it's what I would do
[Music]